plusieurs fois par jour eugénie côté
robitaille doit changer les couches de
sa fille elisabeth à 6 ans elle est
atteinte de la paralysie cérébrale
qu'est ce que tu racontes une condition
lourde de conséquences pour elle et ses
parents
ce vote a pas de repos aux marches repos
en mangeras pas par elle-même
on administre le gavage apprécier tout
le nettoyage de tous les instruments
ça occupe quand même beaucoup de temps
dans une journée mais elles ont adapté
achats de médicaments et d'équipements
spécialisés le handicap d'elisabeth
entraîne des dépenses et des sacrifices
à faire juger ni travail à temps partiel
sébastien a accepté un emploi moins
payant à l'horaire plus flexible le
couple aimerait recevoir un meilleur
soutien financier équitable avec celui
qui est accordée famille d'accueil
moi je trouve ça injuste et je trouve
que ça n'a pas de sens la différence
entre les deux on doit recevoir autour
de 20000 25000 dollars par année
et alors qu'une famille d'accueil en
reçoit plus que le havre presque le
double pour une enfant le comique comme
les habitent
on la donne notre lion mais on ne l'a
pas été on va s'en occuper au maximum
mais ça prend des ressources selon une
étude québec accorde en moyenne 21 mille
dollars par année aux familles
naturelles comptant un enfant handicapé
contre 38 mille dollars à une famille
d'accueil de 3 le gouvernement legault
s'est engagé à établir un meilleur
équilibre mais la réalisation de cette
promesse se fait toujours attendre et
des femmes une longue pause par qui vit
vraiment sous le seuil de la pauvreté
qui sont dans la grosse misère dans la
détresse qui pensent à placer leurs
enfants parce que financièrement n'y
arrive pas le premier ministre l'a dit
si veut que les hommes puissent faire la
différence dans le premier mandat
mais nous on aimerait vraiment déjà
amené une première un premier
soulagement surtout pour les adultes
handicapés puisqu'on a fait déjà des
étapes significatives pour les enfants
le gouvernement le goût maintien qui va
remplir sa promesse mais dans le
prochain budget
ce sont les parrains qui s'occupe
d'enfants handicapés adultes qui seront
priorisés si olivier bâche un réseau
canada montréal